[MUSIC PLAYING]
RUSLAN MURSALZADE: Hello,
everyone, my name is Ruslan.
And today I'm joined by
Oluseye Farodoye, the group
senior manager and head
of services at MTN Group.
He's going to be
talking a little bit
about their digital
transformation journey
with API first approach.
Thank you for
joining us, Oluseye.
OLUSEYE FARODOYE:
Thanks, Ruslan.
Thanks for having me.
I'm excited to
share our journey--
our digital
transformation journey
and how we're leveraging
the power of APIs
to power our new
business models.
A little bit about MTN.
MTN is an emerging
market telecoms operator,
and we operate out of 21
countries within Africa
and the Middle East.
And we are the forefront
of digital transformation
within the regions
in which we operate.
RUSLAN MURSALZADE:
That's great, Oluseye.
I know you're a
champion of APIs,
so tell us a little
bit about what
role do APIs play in MTN
Group's digital transformation
strategy.
OLUSEYE FARODOYE: So
overall at MTN, we
believe that in order to
realize exponential growth,
we have to transform ourselves
from a one-sided business
into a multi-sided platform.
And APIs play at the
very core of that vision
and of that
objective by allowing
us to create new
avenues, to create value,
and to also identify and
capture new sources of revenue.
RUSLAN MURSALZADE: And I believe
you're managing those APIs
with Google Cloud's Apigee.
So tell us a little
bit about how
Apigee is helping you achieve
your digital transformation
goals.
OLUSEYE FARODOYE:
So overall in MTN,
our digital transformation
program, which
is called Oxygen, looks at
transforming MTN from a, not
just one internal
perspective, but also
with external interactions
with our stakeholders
and other businesses
within the ecosystem.
And Apigee has
played a core part
in transforming the
way we do business
and transforming the way
we think about interactions
with stakeholders and with other
entities within the ecosystem,
largely because of the
many capabilities that
come with Apigee that allow
us to be able to roll out
new features and components and
feature sets really quickly.
RUSLAN MURSALZADE: And what
type of business impact
are you seeing so far
with this strategy?
OLUSEYE FARODOYE: Thanks again.
We've seen quite a number
of really impressive impacts
business-wise, but I'll
just take a few of them.
One of them is speed.
We're now able to
deliver new features
and create new services in
about a quarter of the time
it used to take us before.
Right now we're
also able to secure
the interactions between
MTN and entities, especially
with features like Apigee Sense.
We can monitor and manage this
traffic in real time and act
on them.
And overall we also
seeing a very big jump
in operational efficiency.
For example, last year
we processed close
to a billion API
calls and we had
to-- we did this with pretty
much same investment in Apigee
that we had in 2019.
RUSLAN MURSALZADE: That's
great to hear, Oluseye.
Tell us a little bit about
your monetization strategy
with APIs.
Which APIs are you
monetizing, and how are you
identifying opportunities for
new business models with APIs?
OLUSEYE FARODOYE:
So generally we
took a fairly unorthodox
approach to monetizing APIs
by creating a new entity
to tackle the overall API
marketplace or API monetization
challenge within Africa.
And that's called Chenosis.
You can find it on chenosis.io.
And-- but what we've
seen in the market
is there's interest
for APIs in payments,
specifically mobile
money, where there's
a lot of interest for APIs
around KIOC, a lot of interest
for APIs around identity
and verification,
largely driven by the fact
that a lot of Africans
are either underbanked
or unbanked.
And what Chenosis aims to do is
to consolidate this and sort of
create an ecosystem
within the market
where APIs are easily
accessible to the community.
RUSLAN MURSALZADE: That's very
inspiring to hear, Oluseye.
So what's next for MTN Group.
Tell us a little
bit about what you
hope to accomplish in
the next three years.
OLUSEYE FARODOYE: Overall,
MTN over the past 27 years
has positioned itself
and proven itself
to be a technology leadership
organization within Africa
and the Middle East.
And what we aim to achieve in
the next one to three years
is to actually position
ourself as the platform
business for the region.
And we're doing this by
adopting an API-led approach.
We doing this by adopting
new ways of thinking.
And because we know and we
believe that everyone deserves
the benefits of a
modern, connected life,
we are creating new ecosystems
and new sources of value.
And we believe
that by adopting--
I mean, using APIs and
leveraging platforms
like Apigee, we can create
new sources of revenue
and create more value.
RUSLAN MURSALZADE: That's very
inspiring to hear, Oluseye.
Thank you for joining
us today to tell us
a little bit about MTN's
API-first digital strategy
with Apigee.
OLUSEYE FARODOYE:
Thanks, Ruslan,
and Thanks for having me.
And thank you for allowing me
to share our story with you.
RUSLAN MURSALZADE:
For those of you
who'd like to learn
more about this,
please check out
the resources below.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]